I was just talking to the bridesmaids
monkey and I said who's gonna cry first
and then everyone went he always won I
love you but I didn't know that I
couldn't live without you so I moved
away from you once a year I just
desperately need you to take care of me
because I'm a mess
[Music]
morning the try guys are all here in
Chicago Illinois where apparently the
lake looks like an ocean did not know
that I've never been in a wedding before
we're here for Keith's wedding he's
getting married to Becky finally and all
of the drug guys are groomsmen so the
wedding is about to start everyone is
going in there cedar filing in and we
don't actually know what we're supposed
to be doing right now we were mostly
just vlogging during there I suppose
we're at the rehearsal I showed up
wearing maroon but then I changed I'm so
sorry yeah doing his best Eugene
impression impression and I'm just
[Music]
you know explore Chicago for the first
time here's a quick Instagram story
montage
[Music]
thank you I need to happen to hold
hashtag drinky with the guns uh yeah I
like me but you have to say like
[Music]
morning lover you're supposed to be
dressed how will we get dressed as part
of the thing six hours to go
it's the morning of the wedding yes and
things have happened oh yeah I didn't
read that prior there are a lot of text
threads there we are five and a half
hours out and the groomsman has no pants
month yeah I don't need I just gotta go
to the store alright it's alright
there's another way you do except for me
going to the store now one of the best
man Ryan is one of the best and he
brought his pants in to get pressed and
the cleaner gave it back and and the
pants were missing who cleaner goes door
is really hard to find these blues I
mean you might be able to better [ __ ]
try craters are closed so can't get
pants guys well I'm just going to get it
right yeah that's the only option the
other option is you find really
interesting dance that match well maybe
you and I wear them so that's like a
yeah because if there's two it's a
choice that just wanted to mistake chaos
Ryan's pants are missing Brian right now
is sitting outside the shop it opens at
11:00 they tried to get into the
cleaners can't get in close they're
closed on Sunday tried to get the
cleaners home number and get to their
house they're very private people be
watchin I mean his options are what
right now I'm break-in to the cleaners
yeah or check every suit store within a
ten-mile radius of this wedding venue
and hope that somebody has this sweet
color I'm trying to remain calm nothing
about a little wedding morning drama
how do the bridesmaids are doing better
wait where's the rose Miller's
[Applause]
Midwestern is bad Holly that goes from a
county to a tragedy real quick all right
so we got some option photos for
replacement pants these aren't really
great yes sir
not the right color III feel like
Eugene's plan is the best plan we're
finding one that looks like a choice and
having both mark and Brian because you
know otherwise Brian's gonna stick out
yeah
Becky's not gonna like that that's pants
that's two yeah that's a totally
different
black and blue red and gold situation
Keith I feel like slightly I check in on
the bridesmaids right roll-call let's do
it Hannah
how do you know Becky I'm going to
college together and yeah
I'm Andy and I met back the after
college brides man ah [ __ ] soos
I was Becky's roommate in college
Michael Becky's brother Becky the
beautiful bride-to-be how you feeling
what's your favorite memory that you
have with Keats like man to man oh man
to man yeah have you ever leaf road out
ya know I used to go around I asked you
if I can keep yeah like you're very calm
thank you I can't find my talks jewelry
this doesn't make any sense
it's okay try just to me banks then try
Men's Wearhouse we need to be trying
hard to get all the forward so under man
yeah I mean though you should probably
just get into touch with the owners or
fun said oh no no I can do you know I
know Brian's mom was trying to do that
no wonder she's Brian's mom may not we
got here in that's like got northern
suburbs right Alex ready well let's take
a break wait what what Steve and I could
just live it up everything's okay great
we'll see you soon
what what they were hung up in our
closet they must have fallen off the
hanger in the closet that's one be what
grabbed it last night didn't notice that
the pants were not there pants are on
the floor in the closet about 100 feet
away so this is there's no problem
wedding day miracle Oh is the groom
stealing is businessman twins right now
that's kind of the opposite of how it's
supposed to go
what do grooms men do while you wait
pity games you're gonna put this on the
plate yeah and you're gonna take it
you're gonna put it in that where that
room has all those arrows a bunch of
onion soup what must be the most
romantic game of all time I'm taking you
this bowl take that bowl at his place
[Music]
Alberti because I thought that led you
to sell the carcinogen this good nerve
Oscar also I'm trying to create sort of
a backup the near look with some of
these bouquet flowers Mesquite's other
brother who we haven't met yet I'm the
reason he's who he is my senior year of
high school I went on a cruise the
Bahamas that came back with a conch
shell and pep rallies in high school he
started wearing a garbage bag and
blowing on his conch or apparently he
likes an absolute sensation and that's
how he got started performing in front
of people all the time I planted that
scene I am responsible for everything
you've seen so far so basically if it
weren't for that conch show there'd be
no try guys there would be nothing good
gather on the brink of emotion
constantly let it out there yeah I have
to wait till Peck he's there at least if
I can make it that way
[Music]
I'm doing good feel great just feel like
I'm constantly about to cry for nothing
don't worry you're gonna cry for
something yeah that's true
right now though there's no reason to
start crying no no no of course that's
all right but I'm writing his stern
minutes away I can't start now okay big
non-emotional thoughts like the state of
the world when did you know that Keith
was the one dating and he was really
sweet kind hearted and Becky really
never talked about her boyfriend before
yes just wanted us to meet him she loves
her kids
yeah she loves her keys and Keith loved
her miss Bonnie and he's very well she's
funny so they're really fun together
yeah you gotta keep together
Eugene's been saying this for a week you
say Keith cries I'm gonna lose my [ __ ]
I'm like on the verge of crying all the
time this week how we gonna cry and I'm
gonna try to be the last bastion of I
don't trigers wreck I don't think I
cried sure I would love to cry for you
if I don't act that's nice it's not a
it's not a requirement I decide to go
bad if I don't cry when I cries okay
mine you seem kind of through that like
a challenge so I'm like [ __ ] you I'm
gonna cry so I guys try crying yeah
[Music]
I am Ricky Hoffmeyer I am here today to
celebrate and support
in a Becky Miller daughter have done and
Miller and she have this burger son this
burger
six years ago you took me on our first
date while I sat there pretending to
like wrestling I love it to myself this
is kind of a strange day but it didn't
matter how strange the date was because
it only took me a few minutes to see how
kind here especially i promise i'll
always save you half of my fried chicken
I promise I will always have your back
and take care of you I promise I will
always go dancing with you even when
we're 50 and tired from taking care of
our 25 rescue dogs
every time by the weddings I watch other
people get married
[Music]
I see other people read their mouths and
I can only think about my balance
and I can only think about Mary
we've been together for six years and I
knew I loved you before you were going
to go on a date with me and I've always
wanted you but I didn't know that I
couldn't live without you so I moved
away from you once a year
[Music]
I've never thought I could feel so much
for a person you
I just desperately need you to take care
of me because I'm a mess solving
I've been tremendously lucky to be
surrounded by so many great friends a
supportive family as supportive new
family and so many people who are
important to me
but no one is the
and nothing
or thieves you
I wrote something fix long and
repetitive but ultimately I just want to
promise you that I will love you forever
I will always show you affection I will
always be happy to come home to you
after work
I will always be sad to leave you let it
go to work I will always care for you
that you were sick or hurt it'll always
celebrate you and celebrate with you
when you are happy
and most importantly promised to be your
best friend
to see you are - and all of these things
are promises I have to make but there
are things that I no intention of ever
not making as I love you so much
I'll never stop
they got me not a dry eye in the house
did you cry oh my god so much I probably
don't have makeup on right now so I can
cry if they thought I'm only gonna cry
but keep Calvi then marriage is
beautiful are you doing great the big
day for me I think are they already like
they doing it where they Wow they
consummate immediately
wah I'm even able to eat it all do a
bite I'm honored to have gotten a
glimpse got the love that you guys have
for each other and I just know that it's
just like the tip of the iceberg in that
sense your relationship it's just so
much deeper and stronger than anything
that I could ever see from the outside
congratulations
[ __ ] I can't top that Becky yeah we made
a try guys video your wedding we're
sorry but I think we should end it with
you because it's your day and it's your
way of marriage I mean say white period
Stroheim Americans okay this is a blog
it was a blog